claire sous l'égide de la turquie oui
d'ailleurs rejeb tayyip erdogan le
président turc sera là tout à l'heure au
palais de dolmabahçe à istanbul pour
accueillir les délégations russe et
ukrainienne avant de s'envoler pour
l'ouzbékistan où il est attendu pour une
visite officielle alors qu'attendre de
ce nous aussi l'émotion le ministre
ukrainien des affaires étrangères l'a
dit hier à la télévision nationale
ukrainienne le programme minimum ce sera
les questions humanitaires donc on peut
le supposer surtout à marioupol et
autour de marioupol pour mettre en place
des couloirs humanitaires le programme
maximum ce sera un cessez le feu mais
c'est le programme évidemment le plus
ambitieux les négociateurs ukrainiens
ont déjà annoncé qu'il ne fallait pas
s'attendre à d'avancée majeure
au niveau au niveau rue sans ce qui a
changé depuis la dernière fois où russes
et ukrainiens se sont vus en face à face
et la situation sur le terrain qui
semble dessiner une dynamique plus
favorable aux ukrainiens et qui sont le
montrer que les russes s'embourber ce
sera très certainement refléter au
niveau des négociations pas question
pour les négociateurs ukrainiens de
parler de changement de régime ou de
changement de gouvernement à kiev pas
question de revenir sur l'intégrité
territoriale ukrainienne et de faire des
concessions territoriales donc ça reste
quoi comme sujet éventuellement on l'a
dit les questions humanitaires et aussi
la question de la neutralité de
l'ukraine et sa dénucléarisation voilà
quelques sujets qui seront peut être
abordée tout à l'heure à istanbul